from the New York Post quote she was 12
I was 30. Biden leaves viewers stunned
in teachers speech uh correction to your
post the crowd cheers for him he laughed
loudly they laughed loudly in the high
it's very funny when a guy makes a joke
about that's a that's a that's a very
large age Gap you've got there they say
president biting shocked viewers on his
Friday speech teachers when he
recognized an audience member and told
the crowd she was 12 and I was 30. body
lit up social media with the confounding
and seemingly inappropriate aside he did
not say what he did when he was 30 and
the wind was a pre-teen you got to say
hi to me Biden said mid-speech at the
National Education Association
headquarters in DC we go we go back a
long way she was 12 and I was 30. but
anyway this woman helped me get an awful
lot done huh as a 12 year old
that's maybe later in life but what's it
why would he bring that up I don't know
what is she helping him get done who is
this woman anyway this is all a mystery
to me so there's there's two
possibilities here one he's absolutely
brain fried and can't even talk properly
two he's a very dirty perverted bad
person well that's a fact that we can't
even mention and there's there's a lot
of other activity that happened before
this whether it's the Ashley Biden diary
whether it's the bunch of creepy videos
that are being censored by big Tech
social media whether it's him kissing
his granddaughter on the mouth two times
whether it's him at least two times that
we know on record and him being a career
politician when you're in Washington DC
we know for a fact intelligence agencies
use
um sex and use underage children as a
form of extortion as a form of
manipulation so him being in Washington
DC this long and and so many other
things that happened beforehand
definitely raise some serious questions
from my perspective
I just wanna I'm pulling this up right
here and hopefully this this image comes
so when people are like why do you think
Joe Biden's a pedo well it's like well
here's him kissing his granddaughter on
the lips as well the public crowd how
much time do you have yeah she's
definitely kissing him too that's how
many
days
loving it like look how happy they all
are it's the weirdest thing isn't it
yeah mouth kisses is kind of a weird
thing is am I missing something look I
don't know I don't know what world y'all
y'all are from the world I'm from
family members kissing each other on the
lips is like not a thing it doesn't
happen yeah I remember it when I was a
kid my grandma kissed her on the mouth
once and one time I felt like her
wetness out of the between the lips
because they were drinking whiskey yeah
but why is everybody like staring at Joe
Biden kissing his granddaughter it's not
the only time he's done it but they're
all very happy about it like they're
laughing he was also referred wasn't he
referred to as Pito Pete by somebody was
in that thing recently if you remember
that as well and you know the behavior
there is is is is very eye-opening and
again you could jump to your own you
know assertions and conclusions but
there's there's a trail of behavior here
that is where we saw look at here's
another one like what it I don't get it
is this like a like a Delaware thing
people in Delaware like kiss their grand
their grandchildren on the lips
thanks oh man yeah that's oddly specific
yeah I think I think Joe Biden abused
Hunter it explains all of Hunter's
Behavior it was Hunter at least
allegedly they called him Peter Peter uh
I don't know where that came from if it
was like in his texts or something that
was like the phone backup that got
released right yeah I've only heard I
haven't like seen I don't even know how
I would verify it if I saw it if I would
even be real or not but it's a little
disturbing if that's real and all the
teachers are cheering for it right yeah
yeah I guess so you'll see people I'm
sure with this being reality he's like
today we're gonna get into the Savage
about and they're like yeah
that's making noise when he said a
pressure and they're like yeah yeah it's
like what the it's like it's going on
it's the emotion the tone cue and that
makes everyone clap and cheer but it
like it's not even a logical it's
expression it's very I kind of feel like
if you had a stage with Biden on it and
then his supporters on stage with him
but like you could see it and then he
said something like next no Russian
battle calf care and they'll start
cheering I'd be laughing like this is a
great show this is hilarious these
people are so dumb
it's the world we live in I guess that's
our president meanwhile the economy is
imploding you got uh the market tanked
what is it uh the the Dow Jones fell
below what it I think when Biden first
started it was about thirty thousand
three hundred now it's down to 29 so
yeah the economy is worse in this
picture the the Dow is down you can see
the red and the arrow oh yeah look at
this even that's amazing look at this
clip right there as we're showing Joe
Biden talking about some 12 year old
that he knew when he was 30. it's you
can see the Dow watch showing a drop of
nearly two percentage points so yeah you
know how you guys doing
all right I'm looking at the Dow
all time
um it's tough it's tough to tell because
they'll print large amounts of money
that'll naturally inflate the Dow just
because there's more Capital doesn't
mean the economy is doing better though
well you know just to put on my
conspiracy hat if I could
um just just for a little bit here let
me dust it off here a minute uh if if
you do look look at a lot of the Biden
policies they have directly created this
economic Havoc that we're dealing with
for the benefit of the few ruling Elites
and this is why a lot of people make the
assertions and theorize that maybe there
is some dirt on Biden that's some very
powerful people have on him that they're
using to of course influence policy in
America policy in America that's not
working in the best interest of the
American people working in the best
interest of the select few who might
have dirt on him and they're using that
dirt in order to push these policies
wrecking the economy maybe maybe but I
think dirt's the wrong way to look at it
I think it's more like you can do what
you want if you do as you as you're told
you know what I mean yes and then there
could be an extortion operation I I
think that's a little bit more likely I
don't know you were
I think in general terms I think it's
less about stuff like that I just think
it's more that large businesses the
elite have really significant lobbying
power and donation power and you know
their businesses can donate and super
Pacs can donate you know if you think
about you know our GDP and our success
almost all of it comes from small
business because small business you guys
know this you're a small business you
hire people you know you're always
growing you're thinking about how do I
do more how do I get bigger large
business thinks about efficiency
offshoring saving money and so there's
nobody that represents the average
American the small business owner
there's nobody that is truly putting
money time lobbying efforts into that
and so you know you end up with people
that are that only care about you know
significant interests
I wonder what Biden does when he like I
think he sleeps most the time and then
they wake him up and give him pills or
you know maybe they're yeah maybe
injections they've got uh big businesses
very much about the stockholders and
forever it's been about stockholder
value stockholder now they're they're
adding on shareholder value uh share am
I is am I getting this right well that's
like the the Klaus Schwab thing is like
planetary stakeholders I think it's
stakeholders now they're going from
shareholders which are the stock owners
to uh stakeholders as well which is who
has stake in this company doing well
which honestly is up for It's Up For
Debate like
if it's a company that wants to clean
the water in Portugal then all of the
Portuguese citizens become a stakeholder
in that company doing well and then they
can I don't know enough about it to
start going off and I've actually been
starting to read class Schwab's recent
book um and I'll definitely let you know
more but it's you know it's a way to
manipulate to get corporations like ESG
is like are you doing well for your
stakeholders as well as your
shareholders are you making the world a
better place for your stakeholders the
ESG stuff is the Communist Party of
America the the so you have the
Communist Party of China and what they
do is they get an office in all of these
companies you open a company you got to
have they got they gotta have an office
there and they control if you're in line
with the message and at some point some
U.S interests were like man that's a
good idea we could totally control
everything if we just forced this so you
had this uh this guy um Vivek uh
Swami there you go there we go yeah he
was ragging on Disney because he was
like you're doing things that are
hurting the company for for ESG stuff
like stop doing that and then he even
called that State Street Vanguard and
was it BlackRock I think so yeah he was
like just because they're big
shareholders doesn't mean you do what
they say they represent people and the
people don't want any of this stuff but
here's here's the thing man these those
three like that they own basically
everything they've got huge percentages
of basically everything super woke ESG
they're trying to control it's it's you
know what it is it's kind of like
I don't know if who is the right word
because not like they're storming the
gates and taking over but they're
they're definitely slowly taking over
everything and they're doing it through
the private sector and the and the
public sector to be honest but they're
they're going to the private sector
through ESG as basically the Communist
Party of China does and they're they're
getting their offices they're getting
their influence and then if you don't do
as you're told you get banned you get
you get the acts you get shut out of
society we can't let them gain more
control simply put gotta fight back
how do you do that start small
businesses
start your own business make your own TV
shows incorporate mock Disney as they
collapse yeah so he's telling Disney
he's like you've got to stop this and
I'm kind of like no wait don't like
don't let Disney rot itself to the core
okay we'll make we'll make our own show
with Ian that's right and no hookers and
bucko yeah we're just talking today
about a lot of content is like people
are are creating like Christian content
like there's pure flicks which is
starting to ramp up their Hallmark has
their own daily wires I never heard yeah
since 2005 but people don't want to be
bashed over their head with it so you've
got to figure out what's the next phase
and I think the next phase is sci-fi
that takes into account like the
cosmology and this new physics where
we're finding like Cosmic microwave
background radiation that kind of looks
like neurons in the brain and you're
like wow maybe there is a God and if you
can kind of take people in that
direction you know you can kind of bring
God into the conversation and kind of
ground it in like morality but still
have cool sci-fi message on top of that
I mean the whole thing kind of depresses
me because I I remember there was a time
where there it wasn't like right content
or left content you know it was content
like a movie or a show or whatever you
know was about you know whatever the
topic of the day was or but it wasn't
like you watched a show or a host or
whatever because they had a specific
view it was you know you came on you had
discussions about complex topics and
people got into it and they could
disagree and that was acceptable and I
definitely feel like
um and you know full disclosure like I
said earlier I'm moderate
um I do feel like if you're a
conservative you know you have fewer
opportunities to have your voice heard
and you see it in businesses like I have
friends that own
um you know whether they're Second
Amendment businesses or or 2A adjacent
like I have a friend that owns a company
called fieldcraft survival Mike Glover
oh yeah we love Mike he was on the show
yeah a few months Mike's amazing I mean
he's one of the best people I've ever
met and um you know he's essentially you
know targeted as almost a domestic
terrorist and it's insane this is a guy
that you know served you know in Special
Forces you know I have not found a
single human being that doesn't like him
and you know the special operations in
military Community is a lot like a
sorority where people like to talk about
each other you know there's a lot of
that like everybody's got a little bit
of a beef with everybody no one has said
anything about Mike Glover everybody's
like he's the best dude on planet Earth
and his content is constantly you know
pulled down and he's just telling people
how to survive in a crisis and didn't
defend feds attack him and label him
like a domestic yeah yeah what was what
was the story explain it to people
because that's a big one yeah he he is
on a list like field Craft Survival Mike
Glover they're on a list as like
potential domestic terrorists and like
this guy would never do anything against
this country like I mean he he is a you
know and people throw this term around
for people that don't deserve it like
he's a true patriot
um and uh
I mean you know he's he's a big part of
uh Tim Kennedy's life who who's you know
been a friend of mine for years
um you know I know him personally all of
my friends have worked with him or you
know in whether in the military or
business and this is a guy that's like
he owns a survival company so he teaches
you you know to shoot to hunt to you
know dress wounds to live in the wild
that's what he loves doing so that's
what he teaches people to do like how do
you survive in the worst possible
situation and um
yeah like you know he's been flagged and
it's wild to me like there's no undoing
it either thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at
8pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there